hey guys how's it going so today we're
in my kitchen as you can see and I'm
with my new friend Alex hi everybody so
what are we gonna do today
do you even know cuz I'm actually not
really sure either Justine tricked me
into coming over here and she's got
these everywhere and let me tell you
what I have digit spinners
so against the fidgets spinners but I
thought it would be really funny because
f is for funny to make a fidget spinner
cake you know what else what is an F
word fondant use fondant to put on the
fidget Spooner cake we need an S word
for the spinner part so this these are
like the dark ages of the inner what's
three four five visits tips for in five
okay here's the thing I got these on
Amazon Prime now and these are not even
quality digits fitters F is for fun
that's right look I'm a super anxious
person and I always actually fidgeting
and this does not do it for me well what
we're doing really wait wait maybe we'll
spin it out wait wait I've got an idea
I've got idea what we haven't even
started baking yet I was gonna say if we
put it on this cupcakes but then we put
the cupcake on my head I'm really
worried that I'm somehow gonna shoot
more weight I have an idea
yeah I have an idea hold on but if we
tie the cupcake on my head alright wait
that's not gonna work at all well poke
it through and then you'll tie it
underneath I didn't know I was doing it
so well this wasn't something that I
planned for
okay well now we're gonna make a cake
okay number one cake number two I just
learned how to use fondant have you ever
heard of fondant mm-hmm so it's really
dark a cupcake yeah thank you do you
bake off date boss I do bake these cakes
surreal
yeah oh I have the best chocolate chip
cookie recipe I'm worthless
why you made these cakes I'm sure they
did spin around your head Jenna made
those games all right so I couldn't find
a cake board so you know I didn't bring
what you wanted me to bring don't worry
because I've got plenty I totally forgot
No Oh No so I used to juggle no you well
I mean if I can just but I mean you see
like my job and she wanted me to have
her juggle knives and I totally Shh it's
okay cuz I've got plenty of other things
we can juggle around here do we flip
this over am I doing this right
the good news is you can draw correct
yeah great so I'm gonna need you to draw
this fidgets butter on here do you need
a pen mmm-hmm well I've got edible
markers this looks nice
your artistic tracing ability is very
excellent I don't like you with knives I
hate it is that why you can't push me
watching cutting I'm cutting right is
this sharp
yeah it's sharp okay juggle this one oh
cool do you have more I've got the other
hand you could do it
I'm telling you wait do you have
something else we should practice do the
spatula first let me see if the spatula
yeah you could do it yeah but I don't
want to f is for flipping the night
great job so now what we need to do is I
sit oh my god you've so much frosting
we're putting more on top of it yeah
you'll see it I've never used fondness
me either I use it for the first time f
is for first not too long ago there's
this guy he has a channel man about cake
and he is an incredible Baker he taught
me how to do this so this is my first
time doing it all by myself
nope please she told me we were gonna
make a total mess I haven't made a mess
yet okay so now that I have got a new
look I already is in the way it seems
like you have a because that looks nice
this kind of like Mickey Mouse how did
some of things happen but like nothing
has happened yet it is so good it's very
good okay yeah I brushed my hair so I
feel real pretty for this next shot
stood that icing on my face how many
things can you juggle at once for a
cupcake for you to do it I thought you
were well you're gonna do it she can
juggle to you guys I'm not the only one
I do it all the time how you doing have
you done it with Frost I got him not
with frosting that's what we're doing
right now this is actually better
because another heavier you would think
that one too
[Laughter]
[Music]
it can't be good for your body that's
something we have to look the same
yeah I can't believe you know that like
you're gonna have a tummy ache
yeah doesn't this look just like a
fitted spinner you okay it doesn't
though unfortunately I was so excited I
was like this is gonna work out great
it looks like a uterus no they show you
in health classic video okay like this
is your body this is your body we need
to discuss French time yes
fridge okay so this is fondant right I
don't know really like what it is but
it's cool you bought it at the store no
Josh brought it over so what we're gonna
do is do this okay we're gonna mash them
together
and then we're gonna roll it out yeah
now it's three ways I called marbleize
Alexa play roll out
[Music]
what can I get back to business did you
like my whoa did you just slap me I feel
like she finally let it out I can't
believe you just slapped me listening to
Ludacris again I get real rowdy Alexa
plural Allen oh yeah yeah I remember the
cake being a lot bigger than that I
thought it was too I'm gonna lift this
up drop the cake down we place this over
top of it does it taste like anything I
can taste like this piece right yeah do
you like the taste
mmm it's part of a bigger project sure
like you're paid to like it no no II
just was like hey here's some fondant I
pass but if it was in a cave I'm really
I thought this was gonna go all downhill
around about when she had the cupcake on
her head I was like this is over
[Music]
they're going to put this little guy
right there
[Music]
[Applause]
we're gonna do now Alexa tell us what to
do learn about the world in the universe
I can answer questions like what's the
population in Australia and how hot is
the Sun okay so right now we're gonna I
use love to some more cupcake and we're
gonna put fidget spinners on all of them
then we're gonna spin the fidget
spinners and then we're gonna get the
cake and wear this in the cake and the
fidget spinners all at the same time and
it's gonna be fun you may ask why would
we do this when a better question to ask
is why is the washer I feel fantastic
alright about what else I was gonna do
you're gonna juggle the night oh thanks
so this makes me question on if it's
edible
[Music]
yeah that's pretty good it's really
incredible
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
we finally did it
can you freakin believe it it's a frenzy
fidget Sparrow finale ness I had so much
fun
freak me too thanks for hanging out
friend freaking spin faster fidgets big
figures of speech it's finally over
ok thank you so much for watching I had
a very very fun time making a fidget
spinner kay um are you cheating and
looking up F words using your freaking
phone leave your favorite f-word
comments below we really need your help
please make sure you check out this
channel I'll put a link in the
description and also the little eye
thing here and however else it is that
you find people's channels mm-hmm she's
gonna voice one of the oh sorry what
were you gonna say I forgot I think
she's gonna say what kind of videos do
you make I was baiting you ok what kind
of videos do you make I rate cartoons
and Justine's gonna voice one about
moped fail I had I see you later well
you know what you think that like I
should make next cuz clearly this is
which one is your favorite you know to
be honest with you I don't think I
haven't asked
oh I thought we were having a
conversation we're finished
[Music]
[Applause]